it's Alex Edelman everybody yeah
um Alex we are here at the news desk uh
would you hit some headlines with us yes
I'm very excited I am too okay let's get
right into it first up Insider reports
that Nicholas Cage says that thanks to
Moonstruck fans have walked up to him
and literally slapped him in the kisser
that's right ever since Cher famously
went snap out of it people have actually
reenacted that moment on Nick Cage's
sweet face or his punim I should say and
he says quote it's part of the job
that's really nice of him yeah that is
nice of him yeah that's not part of the
no I don't think it is I do quote that
all the time like sure snap out of it
when she had I wait a minute hold on I
really like your share oh yeah you like
that it's the first time I've done
schnapper out of it not bad but if I saw
Nick Cage I'd be like could you do me a
favor and just put on that white tank
top from Conair because I like you in
that like tank top from Conair thank you
Nick Katie Rossi yeah I liked it I want
to be like a felon and just in the plane
with him you know what I mean let's do
this so you can just walk up to I would
love to walk up to Nick Cage and then
slap him he's like Moonstruck and I'm
like no Ghost Rider
I didn't like Ghost Rider you know yeah
uh what do you do if somebody's in one
of your comedy shows and they're giving
you that Vibe because it happens in
comedy oh my God I always had this
comedy I was at this comedy club in
North Carolina not to brag and uh and
there was this guy in the front row and
his arms crossed and he wouldn't laugh
at anything and at some point I leaned
over with off the microphone and I went
do you not want to be here and he said I
don't want to be here and I said I don't
want to be here either
show we were like best friends like that
was the thing that totally did it's
amazing yes it ends up in a Sweet Spot
yeah yeah of course all right next up in
the New York Post says hey if you've got
a little romance brewing with somebody
your laughter might be giving it away
and it's scientific because a new study
tested this by recording audio
conversations between friends and
between people with romantic feelings
for each other and when participants
listened they could tell which was for
which just by the sound of the laughter
really yeah laugh between friends
sounded loud and natural you know like
we really bust a gut but last between
lovers sounded more
submissive and like baby like you know
what I mean and I think there's
something to that because when you're
flirting you do that giggle I've never
giggled with a friend like we like you
know really laugh is that your share
again are you doing no I guess that was
my Snapchat
but also they said people with romantic
feelings right like the laugh of someone
that you just started dating versus the
laugh of someone you've been dating for
like three years oh different they're
different laughs they're like oh
hilarious you know like New Year's in
like oh God it's every it doesn't matter
show me the funniest comedian in the
world and I'll show you uh the wife or
husband who is absolutely so sick of
their jokes
yeah
I'll tell you I don't know do I I think
you do I can tell when you're kind of
interested or you think somebody's kind
of cute you can't 100 yeah is it obvious
to me to me it's obvious because I know
you so well but I mean yeah I could tell
yeah
oh my God I better watch it all next
time I see it I'll ask you after I'd be
like is there a little something there
and uh guys I'm right here
[Applause]
give it to us because I gotta tell you
I'm it's weird yeah well it's the big
peanut butter debate It's Been
Everywhere I can't believe we're having
this conversation but we have to is
peanut butter a liquid well CBS news
reports the TSA they think so they've
officially said it is yes a liquid so if
it's in your carry-on your peanut butter
needs to be 3.4 ounces or less
and the internet is shocked and appalled
by this ruling but the TSA says if you
can spill it spray it spread it pump it
or pour it it is a liquid
um okay you know one of those jars of
peanut butter are like 16 and a half
ounces yeah I'm gonna have to buy a
travel size peanut butter yeah that's
what you need well you're actually in
love that you mentioned that Alex
because
we we put some peanut butter you have a
tray too you have one right here oh my
God you get your own uh personal uh
peanut butter travel set so they said if
you can spread it spray it pump it so
we're trying it right now is that what
these lab coats are for oh yeah oh
laptops put it on let's be safe yeah
ready there you have it has the TSA I
have tried to get peanut butter off a
spoon or a knife it's not liquid well
look I'm trying to peanut butter spray
and nothing's coming out or nothing
because you can't spray it paste it's
like well not with that attitude you
know
here's the thing I wanna if it is indeed
a liquid that means that there is a
gaseous form of peanut butter and I I we
need to find that element because like
butter gas yeah I think I've had it
well I gotta tell you everybody you have
to check out Alex's show it's called
just for us it's making its Broadway
debut June 22nd tickets are actually on
sale now and I will advise you to get
your tickets because his show is
supposed to run for three weeks it ended
up running for nine months and then
moving to Broadway because it's
brilliant and um you got to go see it so
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you